can speak live now to the health
Minister Maria Caulfield who's on the
program for us today thank you so much
for being with us
um I just want to start on that tragedy
four people dying I mean it's literally
freezing out there in the dark I mean
how desperate would you have to be to
get on that boat well I think people are
desperate but also uh they're under
criminal gangs who are making thousands
of pounds uh per journey and I think as
the Home Secretary said in the House of
Commons today that's just a sheer
example of why we need to end this
practice there are legal routes into
this country which people can follow we
know that a lot of those people who are
traveling in the small boats are
economic migrants rather than seeking
Asylum are there legal Roots because I
know that there are safe and legal
routes if you're from Hong Kong or if
you're from Afghanistan or if you're
from Ukraine but is it true to say there
are legal routes into the UK to claim
Asylum seeing others from our
humanitarian perspective you know since
2015 we've taken over 400 000 people and
you're right for people from Ukraine uh
people from Afghanistan from Syria area
from Hong Kong and the Prime Minister
said when he made his announcement at
the dispatch box yesterday that he's
willing to look at further safer legal
routes in for people who are claiming
Asylum but we have to deal with what's
happening now in the channel and we know
that a significant percentage of those
are economic migrants who are illegally
entering the country under uh the you
know the the rule of these people
traffickers and this is a classic
example of why we absolutely must end
this and as the Prime Minister said
enough is enough but you appreciate
though that of course I don't think
anyone would dispute that there are
economic migrants as well but there are
also people who have faced persecution
and there are no safe and legal routes
for many of the people on the boat into
the UK to claim Asylum well I think we
have been you know extremely generous as
a country and I think that you know
whether it's people opening up their
homes uh to Ukrainian families uh this
year or whether it's taking in uh you
know people from Afghanistan and Hong
Kong we have shown that when people are
facing uh persecution or Terror that
we're absolutely uh will take people in
but some of people that are coming
through on the small boats who are
claiming Asylum they're coming through
many safe countries first before they
come here because they don't know that's
the point though isn't it because there
are no other ways of them to claim a
sign but there is no reason how to be in
the UK in order to put that claim but
there is no reason why they have to come
to the UK to claim Asylum if you're
traveling through Germany and France uh
to get here there's no reason why you
have to claim asylum in the UK and the
Prime Minister has been clear he will
look at safe and legal routes but we
cannot continue with this uh the numbers
of people crossing in those small boats
we know it's putting pressure on our
Health Service on our schools on housing
and part of his five-point plan is
reducing the cost of uh you know that
we're currently spending millions of
pounds a day on hotels and putting
people up but you know it's not fair on
people who come here legally that there
are ways into this country
um uh that you know are bypassing all
the rules I was having a look when I was
researching you know this interview
about the percentage of Silent cases
that have been decided within six months
and I was pretty shocked actually it's
plummeted from over 80 in 2014 decided
within six months to less than 10
percent in 2022 the turnover of Asylum
case workers in 2021-22 was 40 I mean
what the Earth is going on this looks
like a system that's completely broken
well I think the the Prime Minister and
the Home Secretary have acknowledged the
failings in the system I think the Prime
Minister was very honest about that and
has set up uh you know the five-point
plan where he wants to get through the
backlog of claims by the end of next
year that he's putting extra resources
into dealing with those claims and
they're also that you know tough
reinforcement that you know if people
come here illegally they won't be able
to stay and return and claim to stay so
the backlog is one of the key areas of
his plan uh that we absolutely need to
to get through because it isn't fair on
those people who come here either to be
waiting you know sometimes years before
a decision is made if people have come
here illegally we need to assess their
claim and then there will be strict
enforcement in terms if they've got a
legal claim that will be upheld if not
then people can't just stay here but you
acknowledge that under conservative
government situation is not nowhere near
where it should be well I think we've
had two years of covid so let's not
pretend that we haven't had problems uh
in the last two weeks back from 2014.
yeah so so you so they have you know the
Prime Minister has acknowledged that
it's one of his key priorities to clear
the backlog by the end of next year
because that is one of the problems that
we've not been able to process the
claims uh as quickly as we would like he
said that from the dispatch box that he
doesn't want to see this in months and
years he wants to see this in days and
weeks okay and now I want to talk to you
about the nurses strikes um you were a
nurse specializing in cancer treatment
at the Royal Marsden so you understand
more than most people What It's Like on
the front line of our hospitals I'm sure
many of your former colleagues probably
you know going out on strike from
tomorrow are they wrong to
um I personally don't support strike
action I'm I don't think their concerns
are wrong I think you know I worked uh
during as a nurse during the the Covey
pandemic and I've worked shift since as
well so um and dealing with the backlog
caused by covid is you know ex
exceptional hard work what are their
concerns then so pay obviously is is one
of those but I think it's much more than
pay I think it's about the long hours
that nurses work often not finishing on
time they don't get protected Learning
and Development time like doctors do for
example and skill mix for example on the
wards it can be it's not just about
numbers on the walls it's the level
experience and skills that are available
too so when I've met with Pat Cullen for
example they're the sorts of issues that
the Secretary of State wants to talk
about in terms of improving the working
conditions of nurses and pay is just a
tiny element and I think the strike
action is more about um from talking to
my colleagues is more about their
frustration about working conditions
rather than pay itself so even though
you don't you say you don't personally
agree with strong connection you've got
Sympathy For What someone else I think
nurses have got you know have had a a
very difficult time I don't think
anyone's denying that I just don't see
what's striking achieves I'm very much
you know Keen to work with Pat and the
RCN to look at those conditions as is
the secretary State when he met with her
this week but we cannot meet the demands
of a 19 pay rate just talking um you
know about
um Pat Cullen and about the meeting with
Steve Barkley because she was pretty
disparaging about what came out of that
meeting she said that Steve Barkley
showed belligerence he refused to
discuss pay he was nothing short of
disrespectful I also thought it was
interesting to say that she thought the
government was displaying Macho Behavior
towards the RCM because it sees nursing
as female work that it doesn't value
properly I mean it doesn't sound like
you know she really believes the house
secretary has got her back well I'm
sorry Pat feels like that you know I
know Pat very well and she's a you know
very good leader of the RCN and I got
nothing but respect for Pat but we have
to be honest that we cannot afford the
19 pay rise demand that they're
um they're wanting that will cost us 10
billion pounds and you know as the Prime
Minister said the dispatch box today
they was in September because there has
been some questions marks about that
figure hasn't it it's important to say
um you know the ifs say you know the
government saying 1000 some pounds a
household that ifs says more like 640
pounds the thousand pounds per household
is if it was inflation for all the
public sector because we know what would
happen if we if if the nurses get an
above and play inflation pay rise of
course the ambulance workers will want
it of course teachers will work at one
want it so you know this is about if
we've got an independent pay review body
in place that looks at factors such as
inflation School shortages Recruitment
and Retention they come up with a pay
recommendation which the government has
accepted in full so you obviously think
that 90 is unaffordable
um nurses are generally often been
offered around four percent NHS Scotland
is offering 7.5 percent still below
inflation but more generous than the
current thing the current offer on the
table for those in NHS England and Wales
what would be a fair pay rise for nurses
well we we feel that the independent pay
review body to take the politics out of
four percent so and that decision was
made some nurses are getting more than
that so the those on the lowest lower
agenda for change paying some of them
are getting close to nine percent but
the average is it's a recommendation
isn't it though I mean you could overall
it if you wanted and four percent at a
time when inflation figures out this
morning are 10.7 I mean people are
struggling to put food on the table here
aren't they you can see there's been
stories about nurses being forced to use
food banks we could overrule it but in
order to pay for that we can only pay
for that in three ways the first is to
borrow money and we saw just a few weeks
ago when the government borrows money it
can't afford what happens to interest
rates and uh to the market we could tax
people more because it's not the
government's money it's taxpayers money
at the end of the day we could raise
taxes to pay for that I don't think
anyone wants us to do that or take it
within existing budgets and that's quite
a lot of money at a time when we're
trying to clear those covered backlogs
it would mean taking it away from the
surgical hubs with developing Community
diagnostic Centers
um you know the the recruiting say for
example in mental health uh 27 000 extra
staff that that's where that money will
have to come from and as a minister as a
government we have to make those tough
choices and if we've set up an
independent pay review body then we feel
we need to honor that
um and uh you know we're taking those
factors into consideration and we're
fully uh implemented that pay with your
body's recommendation I just want to
have a look at the comparison between
the private sector what's happening in
the private sector and what's happening
in the public sector because the ons
says that pay growth in the private
sector is 6.6 versus 2.2 percent in the
public sector and you can see there uh
private sector pay at going up more uh
generously than public sector pay you
know
government ministers often say that you
know we're having to stomach at this
pain in order to try and beat inflation
but if your worker in the public sector
you might be feeling it's a bit unfair
why should you be the one who's having
to Bear the brunt of the pain and you
look at the more generous rise has been
giving you the private sector so there
are there are other benefits to being a
public sector worker other than uh hey
uh you know your job security is much
more stable pay your energy bill well it
does if you're in the public sector if
you're working in retail or Commerce and
you know in the hospitality sector for
example where they're reducing people's
hours because people aren't going out to
eat and drink as they would normally
with the train strikes people aren't
going shopping like they they would do
normally there's a lot more job in
security if you're in the private sector
you also don't necessarily get the same
sick pay maternity leave uh benefits
that you do or pension benefits that you
do in the public sector so you know and
as I said earlier pay is only one small
part of most nurses um concerns about
working life at the moment when you talk
to to many of them who are thinking of
reducing hours or leaving actually pay
is probably one of the last things that
they actually mention it's the long
hours it's the hard work it's the skill
mix on the walls we can do something and
we are doing something about that and
pays just one small consideration in
that okay thanks very much for being on
the program uh good to talk to you about
two very serious subjects today